I welcome everyone final session for
today I believe we're starting at 3:20
we're going we'll be going to like 5:20
yeah I hope you guys stay with us today
we'll be talking about tens of frames
and actually how the whole tensorflow
fits with spark so I hope you guys stay
and enjoy what we have for you uh-huh
uh-huh is it going to work it's not ok
click now try that try knock oh sweet I
think that you decide the screen
technical difficulties how's that yeah a
carpet all right so the the goals for
today are than you mentioned we're going
to go quickly through the what the deep
learning is we're going to introduce a
little bit about the future learning
what is the feature engineering a very
quick run up of about tensor flow and
then we'll introduce a model we'll build
a model going through the notebook that
we guys we have for us for you are to
recognize objects and images we'll be
using the very familiar this data set to
recognize hand written digital digits
and then we'll be introducing kinds of
frames and then we'll delve into the
editorial side very quickly hi I'm Tom I
feel around for like over close to 15
years a number of continents are the
streamer said that summarizes me I like
big data and the neural networks also
vacuum-tube so if you want go ahead talk
to me after that after you cool and hi
everybody my name is Danny Lee I am a
principal program manager with the azor
cosmos TV team but prior to this I was a
tech evangelist with data bricks and
then I was also the senior director of
data science engineering concur sorry I
could never remember and then and then
before that I was actually also at
Microsoft I was on I was actually on the
team that built what you currently know
is HD insight so I was on the team that
went ahead said hey Steve
we have no big data strategy let's
embrace an open source Linux based
product you're okay with that right so
if that's me and yeah that's it so and
but we also oh right sorry
shameless
if you're into PI spark Tom myself
actually are the co-authors of the book
learning PI spark so there okay that was
a shameless plug we also want to say
thank you so there are a number of
people that we want to thank one is Tim
hunter he's a software engineer at data
bricks he helped us a lot to make sure
that we got the notebooks right
basically corrected all the crappy code
I wrote also joy who will actually be
coming up here to help us she has been
instrumental in helping us get the stuff
done and the law was going to be here
but I guess he skipped out so we'll just
give him then so for those for you folks
who are going to work with us we are
going to you can definitely do
everything we have here as a PI spark in
anakata you using on your own laptop no
pollen all the other thing we suggest
though is actually using beta bricks
Community Edition okay so mainly because
the notebooks are already pre-written
preset up this way okay now if you go to
a kms
PFS I think I wrote it somewhere around
here but if you go there basically oh
you will be able to download all the
notebooks and the slides for the session
so the quick call off for you guys is
basically go to data bricks comm tried a
to bricks click on the right side that's
the free one okay for you guys alright
and then sign up okay that's just
basically go to the sign up process it's
completely free okay so for you folks
bring back the URL oh sorry yes right
there
sorry so if you guys can do that then
that way you can actually not just
follow us along but you can actually run
the notebook themselves as well okay all
right cool thanks I think just yeah okay
so okay so okay we'll skip hands this is
just setting up this is what's going to
look like when you set yourself up when
you sign into data bricks it's going to
look something like this so just in case
you lost the URL Oh
oh okay uh did we put I don't see is oh
did we forget yeah okay okay where's the
nope no that's okay now just write it
down yep
all right so we'll do this right on the
fly okay okay so you're going to get
your notebooks from here you're going to
get DX community edition here dope
you should receive an email that will
give you this URL this is bottom one
when you signup for data bricks in just
in case you forgot that's what it is
there okay so those are your three
primary URLs okay okay hold it for a
minute and then we'll go on
some Greeson how you the AKMs oh it's
action external URL so did I typed wrong
that's right okay
yeah so that's basically we're going to
go to so the aka way so so just give you
some context this one's the presentation
though I do need to update it again and
these are the notebooks ok you're going
to use the ipython version once I
included the HTML once just in case you
want to look at what the output looked
like from running up so that way you
didn't actually have to run it to see
what the output looks like okay so all
right so let's move on to the actual
presentation portion of this yeah yeah
good cool all right so since most of you
guys raise your hands that you know what
the neural networks are we're going to
quickly go through all of this so neural
networks in general they are modeled
from humans brain there's a bunch of
neurons this is a fundamental building
block of any human brain it's called
neurons there's around hundred billion
of them and each of them is connected
roughly to another 10k so this is a very
very high dense graph if you will the
way they work is in essence the neurons
receive the signals from the preceding
neurons are they occur these signals can
be either chemical or electrical
electric and if there is enough build up
of the signal in within the neuron I
will actually propagate a signal further
on in an essence in a very very similar
form this is how the artificial neural
network neural neuron works so we
receive the input from the preceding
neurons get into the summation function
then passes through an activation
function and then if depending on the
activation function whether it depends
what sort of signal it propagates
different types of propagation functions
we have in the pan and sigmoid these are
squashing functions time hyperbolic
tangent will squash that to be the alpha
to be always between minus 1 and 1
sigmoid works in a very similar fashion
is anchored around 0
but it outputs anything between 0 & 1
and the rectifier the linear so we dealt
with anything that is greater than 0
will actually get output so whatever you
get in the standing function in your
neuron will get a serve as an output as
long as it's greater than 0 if I'm going
too fast just stop me great one the one
thing though the definite you'll see
within the tensorflow notebook
themselves is that we actually will be
using real ooh ok we'll explain a little
bit later why but basically it's the
latest and greatest in terms of which
activation function we're suppose to be
working with it actually has to do with
back prop again we'll go into a little
bit later but that's one a quick call
out there okay thanks so an artificial
neural network is nothing more and
nothing less but a collection of neurons
stuck together they can be stuck
together just like in this image on the
right in the inter layers they can be
stuck into alliances like into inner
kohonen network but effectively every
single of those dots is a an artificial
new artificial neuron in a simplest
model a simple neural network can
consist of a number of input neurons and
a single output neuron and then with
this simple structure you can already
build a simple logistic logistic
regression logistic logistic function it
is also probably I want to call out is a
black spot a black box model because the
more complex your neural network gets
the more hidden layers you have
you can't really analyze the connections
just like in a statistical model from
there you go
some examples of neural networks we have
C forward networks that actually receive
the signal at the out on the input and
then propagate a signal through the
output we have the radial basis function
networks where are the neurons have
different different activation functions
and the returned neural networks where
you have actually local feedback loops
within the neurons or within the layer
that in
I help you to generate generate stuff
there are a number of different learning
paradigms just like within the machine
learning we have a supervised and
unsupervised paradigms of learning the
unsupervised paradigms learning you can
see at the bottom here which is the
self-organizing maps you also know as
Kohanim maps where you think about
clustering modes or clustering models
right where you have a segmentation you
aren't trying to find patterns in your
data without knowing what the true-true
data is or what your true target is with
if you have a your target right so you
want to either predict or classify your
data you would use either back
propagation which is essentially
calculating error at the output of the
of the network compares the output of
the network with the desired output it
decides with your target and then that
error gets proper back propagated for
your network and through a for a network
of derivatives it actually are updates
the weights are connecting to different
neurons we also have a memory based
learning which is essentially like think
about your kid and you know trying to
learn different things this is how you
memorize the network's literally learns
to memorize the inputs you are you are
presenting it with applications are vas
and this is just literally a handful of
examples but you can use them to
recognize faces you can train the neural
network to learn to learn to to play
different games I think recently there
was a one of the Atari games got bitten
by by a neural network you can use it to
rip speech recognition so you know Siri
would have one running behind Cortana
will have another one you can classify
objects like we're going to be doing
today but we're going to be doing only
like a single object recognition there
are frameworks and neural networks that
the whole models that actually
from a single shadow would recognize
multiple multiple objects at the same
time okay so what the deep learning is
deep learning is nothing really more
than I knew on network on steroids so
when I presented you with the the very
simple neural network with two hidden
layers a D premiere a deep learning this
new learning model will have multiple
layers and also many many more neurons
within a single area right so in this
simple example or not simple in this
example we have a 22 24 by 2 24 input
image which is a mind-boggling already
in mind-boggling number of neurons in
the in the beginning right and then it
passes through a number of intermediate
layers of convolution and pooling in
order to get to your get to your output
beads in this case it might be a
classification or it might be a
prediction right so actually let me just
add one quick determind so the key facet
here is that as we've gotten more
advanced in deep learning side of things
the key colors that we a lot of our
solutions involve just adding more and
more layers matting more more neurons to
the problem ok so Alex net is sort of
the sort of the one we are referencing
right now but the fact is that there's
also easy G net the is the F net Google
Google net and actually the last year's
winner was resident ok which was from
Microsoft Research Asia and so the
context that the context of the reason
why we're calling up the 2012 one is
because that's when CNN or convolutional
neural networks started becoming old ok
now this has become interesting they are
becoming more powerful they could solve
these problems faster and so up to this
point we were doing things more like SVM
or other algorithms and so because we
thought those were significantly faster
with the advancements of GPUs and other
basic with distributed computing in
general that's actually why all since
CNN's became much more popular again ok
so that's the quick call-out and so
that's why we're in essence that's why
we're doing a tensor flow session here
yep cool you know the like deep neural
networks can't have this nice feature
that you don't have to
really do any feature engineering right
so they can literally feed anything into
your internal network and you don't have
to worry about you know scaling your
data you don't have to worry too much
about you know transforming that all you
know taking log transform in order to
fit it better to your problem or doing a
PCA in order to reduce the dimensions
this these types of networks will
actually do that behind the scenes they
will learn what to extract from your
data in order to separate the signal
from the noise so this is the I think
the best main color for the space yeah
and then practice it means that our if
you want to predict you know we will
actually choose the right tools to do
the right job right so we'll choose ok
if I'm after a high you know our
high-end restaurant the potential
features might be in a location you know
cuisine and then what it takes
reservations versus if you are after a
specialty restaurant you'd be more
concerned about you know the vibe and
then all this stuff so you don't have to
actually specify that in your model like
in a statistical model and you own
that's where where I should learn that
but on its own cool all right so right
now we've been showing your slides and
we were trying to hide from the map and
we're going to continue hiding for the
map ok
so Intel Joyce's are torn out okay you
go wrong I go oh great let's fix this
again
so I guys can have them get the display
ok ok perfect
all right so this is a tool called deep
virtualization tool box ok let me make
though so it's a little hard to see
ok but what you have here is basically
images and then these are the different
layers ok this is a convolutional
Network layer ok this is a pooling layer
this is a regularization or
normalization layer convolution layer so
forth so forth so forth ok so it's a
it's an open source product called deep
virtualization toolbox it's actually
built on top of cafe not not tensorflow
but it's also cool so we thought this
was a good way to sort of give you the
intuition of how images work ok or sorry
okay so I apologize for forgetting my
pointer but basically you'll see that
for example these two neurons are more
awesome dude these two neurons here are
actually more ethnic these two neurons
are actually more active for that
particular image okay four and then if
we go ahead and go down the network
through each layer okay it gets
interesting so in terms of we think when
it comes to heads it's probably this
particular neuron okay so we don't know
we we just going to go ahead and run
some images and we're going to see what
happens because that's how the neural
networks sort of figures itself out so
let's go ahead and run a real live one
now okay so all right joy now that's
what you get yeah all right so you will
see me here okay and do you see
basically this neuron so this neuron
basically is sort of the one that's more
associated with that we didn't plan it
this way it's just this happens by the
fifth convolutional Network layer
basically it's this head so go ahead
come on dude alright so now he shows up
here okay so now you see two heads right
because in other words the edges that
are associated with faces actually end
up showing up in that particular neuron
okay so for the because exactly we have
the kids all right so back to here so
give me a second as I try to remember
how to do this again all right so go so
if we become a deep run the
deconvolution come on all right yeah
there you can see the edges are coming
through the actual like are the edges of
our face are coming through no problem
at all now right so this is the neuron
that's actually figuring this stuff out
okay again we didn't program it this way
it's just this is the way in this case
cafe but the same for almost every other
a deep learning project that's out there
do we set of neurons they'll be more
sensitive for a particular thing in this
case is faces okay so let's get out of
this so but then for example if I was to
show you and at the same time and being
showing my book okay well you know what
yeah nothing right that nothing shows up
there but what happens
you know like all right rope he's the
problem now okay so it looks like it's
actually this neuron up here that's
actually more active to reading text so
if I was to again go ahead and I go see
it's hard to see okay keep your hands
still man all right you can start seeing
the text that's showing up inside the
book right through here for that
particular neuron okay so that
particular neuron with inside the v
convolutional network is the one that
actually figures out that this is a
square edge plus there's text in it so
we can identify that the book for
example okay so then we're going to lean
a little bit more on that particular
neuron to figure that out
okay so this is again we're not talking
about the masses just to give you the
intuition the idea of how the stuff
works okay so as we go through every
single layer there's new data coming in
data cut popping out and because of that
basically it's the neurons itself right
that actually stickers the stuff out and
frankly we don't know where it's going
to go we just have to monitor and watch
how the neural network itself reacts to
it all question there yes I'm sorry
again sorry
oh sorry you're right it's activating a
correct so the question was it was
acting in New Orleans activating filter
he's correct it's activating a filter my
bad on that one yes yeah oh okay
so hopefully that gives you an idea what
is going on behind the scenes when it
comes to know we're at work we included
this particular the people
beep visualization tool box directly
within the slides as well so you guys
can download and try it yourself
the only quick call out is that if it
only works on Mac or I'm going to so
give you the heads-up on that one and if
you you might have some issues working
on a Mac I actually have a pull request
in for max to for it to work there so
otherwise you have to use the docker
instance and that's actually sort of
weird so ok cool thing a next one next
fall so ok to know that ok
all right so oh and I in the slide we
did embed the video so there's actually
the Prince key he's the guy who actually
created this he's actually a video that
explains all that stuff too so that's
actually embedded we're obviously not
going to show that but that gives you an
idea ok so no I thought you don't have
salute huh yeah sorry ok now we are into
the fender flow yes we work so first of
all probably how many of you have heard
about the flow I'm presuming many yes
very quick an open source library from
Google for numerical computations
basically loose on neural networks the
way it actually works is you have edges
like it creates a graph right so in an
essence the whole tensor flow it creates
a graph where the nodes are the data and
the edges are the the operations you do
on the data and that's how you know the
whole tensor fraud whole graph does the
computations behind the scenes it very
quickly gained popularity so I think it
was released into November 2015 and with
Monte was like one of the most folks it
was specifically within two months it
was the most forked big data project in
github period so there's support for GPU
so as mentioned Danny mentioned too
earlier this is really what's coming to
you know what enables building bigger
and deeper you know networks right now
not as I said notes represent
mathematical operations so and like if
you think about a graph and node would
be like an add or multiply edges are you
data that you actually pass through
those through those edges are cut tensor
flow because the the edges are tensors
and then the data flows through those
fences so in a concept if t1 is very 2
by 3 matrix and t2 is the 3 by 2 matrix
the operation is our tensor so we get
our the the operation going through the
our tensor flow in this is a very very
quick you know example of how you
actually you know called that in Python
using the Python API to tend to flow I'm
not going of going to go through exactly
what's happening here because we're
going to have yes examples of that in
the notebooks but this is really
literally what you have to do in order
to encode encode what you just think and
then total frames actually owes alright
you got it
all right so tensor frames basically how
many of you guys are familiar with
Apache spark ok cool
so happy you are so I want to do the
poor man's version of explanation what
it is ok so the poor man's version is
Apache spark is basically a distributed
compute engine ok it's very powerful
because it puts everything in the memory
number one and number two it actually
has data lineage so the important aspect
when it comes to distributed computing
is that when you're processing data
tasks will and Barbee fail when you have
a large enough system tasks will fail in
the case of spark what it has it
actually has a data lineage so it can
actually rebuild what is actually you
what you had lost basically so that way
you don't actually have to reprocess all
your data from where the task it failed
ok why spark is pretty popular it's
actually because of the fact that in
itself offers you four different api's
right now which is Python Java Scala and
our API ok
in fact Felix who was here he's actually
experimenter himself on the our side of
things and
the graph frame side of things now the
source of spark can be any one of these
things so in other words it is a compute
engine not a storage engine okay that's
not its power at all so from a
standpoint of storage storage it
actually hits all these different things
a lot of the open source systems that
are out there it also hits obviously as
they're obviously AWS things of that
nature okay so that's what makes spark
pretty powerful in terms of the
components you can in addition to spark
or were you basically writing similar to
MapReduce functions you can also run
spark sequel which basically looks like
an C sequel not quite but it looks
almost like an C sequel so you can run
sequel queries against your data okay we
also have spark streaming the ability to
go ahead and stream a firehose of events
right through the system without any
problem whatsoever spark is a we will
handle that it also has a machine
learning library called ml Lib okay and
also has graph X which is the graph
range though it's that's sort of going
to be deprecated so because we have
graph frames now so it's I want to
remove that
but the call-out basically is that for a
lot of people that are out there they've
already put their data into spark okay
they also want to run deep learning
projects though because they want to go
ahead and get access to the power of
deep learning the access of neural
networks directly within the context of
SPARC so in other words if you're not
using spark if you're just using deep
learning that's awesome but not just
because that's really cool but also the
part of the other reason that yeah it's
awesome because apparently all of your
data is already clean and it's exactly
the way you want to be right from the
get-go ok but if you're actually like
most data scientists the reality is you
have to do a lot of data cleansing you
have to do a lot of ETL you have to join
other data sets so because you have to
do that a common approach now right now
these days is actually use SPARC to do
it
so tens of tens of frames is the joining
of SPARC and tend to flow together okay
that's the quick call out ok oh sorry
alright the reason we created tensor
frames is because long story short there
is a communication issue when you go
from SPARC ok it'll go in order for it
to talk to Python which is what the
layer four tensorflow is it will
actually have to go through a python
pickle python pickle between those two
processes before can actually hit the
tensorflow in other words we've slowed
down the process massively for no good
reason
okay so what does tensor frames
basically we actually take the data
frame API incorporate tensor flow so we
can actually have the to talk to each
other so we're not actually pickling
anything we can actually basically have
the tungsten binary format from spark
talk directly to tensor flow okay so it
speeds up performance massively and so
what I mean actually I'll show you know
what just as skip ahead you don't have
to worry about what I mean and what the
the kernel density scoring is but the
call-out basically was this here if I
was to do Katie a kernel discus scoring
if I just did Scala UDF's okay this is
the performance but then as I go ahead
and include tensor frames then now alson
is almost half the twice the speed have
to have the duration for it to take it
when I include GPUs boom is even faster
so that's the call-out that now I can
take my spark projects and I can go
ahead and incorporate tensor flow into
it or the other way around
I have tens of flow projects but I need
to do additional processing to the data
so now I can incorporate a patchy spark
into it as well okay so that's the the
quick call out here excusing so
conceptually this is what tensor frames
is okay in the previous set of slides of
Tom Monaghan showed you the operations
that's the tensor flow of computation
graph what tensor frames is is basically
the wrapper around it I can take a data
frame communicate through tensor frames
to the tensor flow computation graph and
then use tensor phrase to get the output
as well okay so basically it is the way
for those two systems to talk to each
other okay yeah that's really good okay
so and then the other two concepts why
from a business perspective you want to
do it basically like they had noted you
can utilize tensor flow with your data
so in other words you already have a
bunch of data city and spark that's
great go ahead and now include tensor
flow party-hardy okay another super
important aspect is this parallel
training to determine optimal high
performers I'm not going to get into the
details of weights and all hyper
parameters but the context is as you go
ahead and
deep learning models you have to
actually figure out how to go through a
massive amount of data basically to
optimize these hyper parameters and so
often you want to do that in parallel
well guess what with tens of frames
you're able to do that now much more
easily I should say okay so that's the
quick call out of white enter frames
okay all right did that one okay so from
the standpoint of getting ready basic to
run the stuff here's actually all you
have to do in order to be able to run it
if you're running from the PI SPARC
shell okay basically just - - packages
tens of frames okay or we're going to
show you how to do it within data works
okay so in other word you don't have to
copy this down we actually have slides
in there that actually show you how to
do this okay and see yeah we're going to
skip through this because this is
actually already in the notebook but I
kept these slides in here for the
purpose of when you download the slide
yourselves you have a reference and what
the stuff is okay so see we're gonna
okay perfect now tutorial setup there we
go okay I did actually write the URL
there we go okay so this parts lower
part because I want you guys to get set
up and we're going to go ahead and get
your basically make sure you got the
database Community Edition up and
running and here's where you're going to
go get the notebooks okay so any
questions before I think this will be a
good time to ask us questions in terms
of to get yourself set up we'll probably
spend the next 10 to 15 minutes getting
and getting people off and running once
you're good to go then we'll dive right
into the demo the the demos and the
notebooks okay yes
I'm sorry could you see it again sorry
Oh correct so the question is is this
running CPUs versus GPUs and because
it's a free edition absolutely its CPUs
versus GPUs now if you actually go ahead
and have your own box that's where you
can run anaconda directly on it by all
means go for it if you've got GPU access
there by all means do it
data bricks also itself includes GPUs as
well so right now for the purpose of
this presentation yeah we're just using
the CPU side of things for now okay yes
correct so he's brought up a very good
question okay so if I was to assume that
my entire environment was the distribute
environment and I was to chunk the data
would I then in fact go ahead and be
slicing some of the edges putting them
on the wrong clusters and ultimately
causing issues okay
that's a very good question the answer
basically is this for the vast majority
of the tensorflow operations they
actually can be run on a single box so
even the training itself is actually run
on a single box what happens is that
because I'm trying to figure out when
I'm training I'm trying to figure out
the parameters and there could be
millions of different parameters what's
happening is I'm actually distributing
that I'm distributing the the
determination of the hyper parameters
that's actually what I'm doing so the
entire tensorflow computation actually
still exists within the context of that
single box so we're actually not
splicing there are projects which allow
us to distribute that actual tensorflow
computation that's true but some of
those are best way I can phrase is work
in progress because of persuasive what
I'm talking about now well okay I'm not
going to get too deep but the context at
least internally what they're doing is
they're mapping out exactly which edge
goes to where and so there basically is
a separate indexing table that explains
to you where the edge is from on one
node versus where the edge is on another
note and where the vertices are and by
doing it's basically your classic graph
not tensor flow graph I'm referring to I
mean your classic graph problem so there
are ways you can do that but even then
those aren't only good for specific
scenarios so it hasn't been completely
solved yet yeah cool all right any
questions or any concerns or any trying
to get yourself set up on terms of the
communities issue
oh oh sure actually I'm going to show
you that now actually yeah perfect okay
so if you guys are already running
actually that literally is the next step
here import notebooks okay so basically
these are these are the steps to import
the notebooks and repeat in other words
run this for all three notebooks
remember run the iPod download and
import the ipython notebooks not the
HTML ones I mean
actually you can even if you want to you
can do that but that's sort of repeat
repeat so you don't need to okay so in
order to import it basically this is
what this is what your community edition
screen is going to look like okay like
this okay I happen to just you shared
but whatever okay just do it wherever
you want to do it usually I do it on the
users personally I just happened to do
it shared this time what you do is that
in here go ahead and right click on a
folder under your name or whatever or if
there's no folder under your name just
right click and then you'll be able to
go ahead and click on import if you want
to create a folder just click create to
create the folder but otherwise in that
just go ahead and click on import okay
that's the first step second step is
good you're going to get a dialog that
looks like this okay all right so so
basically instead of choosing file
you're going to choosing URL okay
alright that's the second step third
step is then now here's an example of
the notebooks just go ahead and click on
it
all right click on the notebook and then
that's where you get the URL so it's you
the ipython notebook will show up okay
and you'll show up in github okay it'll
look something like this and then
basically get this URL okay that's what
you're going to go grab once you've done
that paste it back in here and click on
import and that are those are the steps
for importing a notebook okay so I'm
going to go back to here okay so as a
reminder if you have issues number one
ask us questions number two the other
trick to this also is if you download
the PowerPoint the PowerPoint itself
actually has these slides right embed it
right in there so you can go use it okay
cool okay
any questions import all three notebooks
laughing with me but any questions yes
I'm sorry
so you can create no you can generate
afford you don't have you don't have you
don't put it appear Li whatever you want
yeah yeah yes particular version of
score we should be ready oh right I'm
sorry I think I actually mention it
later by the way but uh but in just in
case you are ahead of us the version of
spark go run is far 2.1 scala 2.11 okay
I think I've got it somewhere in the
slides but actually there's in this cut
cloth so I think point idea Wow cool
there we go okay
so yeah so if you're already ahead then
this is where you going to go okay when
you create the cluster basically what
you want to do is the runtime versions
of spark 2.1 scala 2.11 okay that's the
version you want to have okay there's an
option to do the GPU one but as soon as
you do that they'll ask you to pay so
let's not do that okay so alright so
once you do that then go create cluster
you can use PI data if you want to you
can call it something else completely
cool either way you're not able to log
in okay
so far so good everybody any other
questions thank you okay so now we will
go back to that one looks like this dot
just yeah just don't type everything
there you go and you select that one
yeah okay
sorry no Scala will be 2011 actually
yeah because you had 2.10 for Scala you
actually want the 2.11 we're actually
asking you for your working though so
maybe with the dots you're a scientist
and this is - sure enough can you keep
on that one it takes about three minutes
yeah also it's not right I guess maybe
we're overloading it right now so what
you do in case you are hitting that
issue which is I've seen that happened
before what you do is you change your
availability zone right now it's set to
us to see just change it to do B or 2a
so and you'll be able to spin it up oh
yes don't don't use PI data I was using
that as example yeah we might be all
running over each other at this point
with that name
okay raise the hands on whose radio goes
next such one good idea okay
all right no probably wait then
this corrects call 211 not not called
210 211 because the libraries we're
about to install are specific to Scala
211 yeah yeah oh that means just waiting
for the cost to spin up I'm assuming let
me take a look yeah no it's okay it'll
it'll take about three minutes yeah yeah
yes oh say you say it again please
but we can connect to community now
exactly oh okay that's worried about
that
we're the closest then many oh it should
be six megabytes of the people yeah you
can direct you can want to choose Scala
this one spark to hold on so just change
me this is actually warning you that the
name to this yeah so just change it to
their new name that's all yes yes please
correct because you choose GPU oh so
they're not going to give that away for
free yeah so reminder do not click on
the GPU one that'll ask you for money so
I'm not trying to actually make you guys
pay money here okay the free ones the
CPU one so again
SPARC 2.1 Scala 211 it's going to look
like this
in other words SPARC 2.1 auto-updating
Scala 211 do not hit the GPU on unless
you want to volunteer money okay so I
mean you're more than welcome to if you
want but that's not what we're here for
yeah cool all we're doing everybody
raised their hands on who's who's got
your cluster upper running okay cool
I guess close enough all right all right
cool so now we're going to stall
libraries for those of you who haven't
got a set of no worries like I said
download the slides the slides are there
for to explain how the steps work now
we're going to install the libraries
these are the two things are going to
install to get yourself up and running
to run these notebooks okay the first
one is you're going to create a library
so basically if you were to this is just
me going to my own directory okay you go
click on PI data click on create and
click on library okay you see that guys
so go to whatever folder doesn't matter
just make sure you know where it is okay
but click on create click on library
okay that's the first step
second step is that we're going to
install 10 to flow and we're going to
install vibe hi pie that's all we're
going to do right so basically literally
in this dialogue of new library you're
going to make sure the language says
upload Python egg or pie pie and then
when under install PI package literally
all you're doing is click typing the
name tensorflow here ok and then click
on install library
oh sure that last slice like this ok
it'll be it'll be under just right click
on anywhere inside your area inside your
full workspace click on create click on
library that's how you how you do it ok
so the library name is this one
basically said this is where you go
ahead choose upload Python egg or PI pie
and you're going to type in tensorflow
ok so for us are good guys gotta leave
it here
[Music]
sure what's up do you specify the
company's address email is because we
have to label soon I just put anything
you don't have to do yeah yeah problem
so I know with that I'm not sharing that
oh wait oh it was crumpled yes problem
it was hugging Safari is way making you
know what I did
that's best because there's actually a
button to do it go back I don't know why
if you go back
Oh
go for it I don't know why actually the
robot yes with the robot that one there
and then thanks for that yeah we should
all the time okay so for the rest of you
guys that's the that's the pie pie
portion of it okay and then basically
what will happen is that when you
attacked
tensorflow to your cluster it's going to
look like this okay all right it may
actually say automatically attached
automatically to all clusters that's
perfectly fine there's nothing wrong
with that I just happen to have it
without it but basically you're just
going to go ahead and attach it that's
it okay all right and then the second
step will be
now you're going to install tensor
frames and again these are the pet
instructions in this case you're going
to go new library okay and you're going
to go maven coordinate all right and
then when you choose maven cornet go
search spark packages in Markman maven
central ok all right so basically maven
coordinate search okay yes oh it's great
new library as well
so you're second you're creating a
second library now yes okay all right
all right and then once you do that
you're going to basically in this dialog
type sets of frames now heads up
sometimes this search is a little hinky
so what you might need to do is flip
search spark packages to maven back to
search type back to spark packages but
basically once you type in tensor frames
it should show up like this okay and the
one you're going to choose is the 2.8 s
2.11 okay remember I was very specific
on you need to install a Scala 2.11
spark cluster that's because we're going
to use the Scala to the left-hand tensor
frames okay all right that's what we're
going to use means it also because
tensorflow itself actually had some
interesting dependency so that's why
we're sticking this call to 11 right now
sure right here forgot oh sorry I
brought up a really good point if you're
using edge try not to do that you might
want to use Chrome yeah sorry I should
have said that right in the beginning my
apologies so yeah edge has some Safari
has problems too so yeah running to
problems running using Safari try
switching to chrome yeah sorry
we've tried yeah and actually this is
for is not specific to David available
every single notebook service has a
version of this problem basically
consistently fine chrome is the one that
actually works so so you're going
through a lot of steps right now it's
sort of irritating so like I said it
it's sort of sucks but what's good is
that once you've got that done it's all
installed and then from this point
onward you're going to be able to use
the notebooks and we're just going to
fly through the notebooks portion of
this ok so yeah so this parcel of boring
sorry about that but that's what it
going to look like ok let's say we got
that
you're going to use the the question is
which version of tension frame is a
version you're going to use is - 0 - 8 -
s underscore to underscore 11 okay that
the - 11 represents the Scala version
okay so that's 2.11 okay make sure you
get the one from data bricks not from
Tim Hunter directly ok it's ok actually
it might even still work but Tim is no
longer maintaining his own version of
this so it's actually under the data
bricks library now so ok cool alright so
once this these steps are done it'll
look like this ok a lot all the fun
stuff ok again if it says automatically
attached that's perfectly fine there's
nothing wrong with that if you want to
turn it off that's fine too just make
sure it is attached to your cluster
that's that's all I'm asking ok and then
boom that's it for let's go so I'll go
back to the other screen just in case
you need it but basically that's it
though those are the two things you
needed to do and from the library
perspective and if you've already
imported the notebooks then you're set
we are good ok
any questions any how are you guys doing
on this stuff cool raise the hands on
who's good perfect all right I think
we're ready to start like I said for
anybody else who's missing it you can
probably ping us off the side and or
download the slides like I said the
slides themselves actually have
screenshots for all the stuff okay all
right let's rock it now joy sorry no not
just run it here you're fine
well do you want to clear the results we
don't join a criminal so you're fine
so what do you want on okay all right
cool
all right so we are on this particular
notebook okay so basically this
notebooks generally we we like doing a
lot of our demos in these notebooks
because even though you went through a
little bit hell and high water on the
stuff to get installed it actually
allows you to include visualizations
include markdown things like that makes
a lot easier for you guys you guys are
sure you're familiar notebooks this is
they're a very similar concept okay so
basically the first part of the notebook
basically reminds you of the cluster
setup so everything you just went
through basically was that okay that was
the first thing and then now we're going
to start in this for ML beginners so for
all you guys who are just beginners on
the stuff cool so we are talking about
looking at handwritten digits okay so
the hammer does digits is based off of
the NIST special database 3 which was
actually off the special database 19 I
don't know why I know that I just do
okay so so what you have is basically
Census in high school information that
made up the what you see is here 28 by
28 pixel images 5 0 4 1 okay there's an
example okay so this is what it looks
like
we the process is to digitize that data
it becomes an array for you to go ahead
and start hitting ok so I'm going to
show you exactly what I talked what I
mean by that all right so
things we are going to do is this first
sell so if you're on under import the
data set you see this command here
import endless digits at images data
from tensorflow blah blah blah
basically tends to flow itself already
includes this data set directly I don't
have to import anything new so all you
got to do is run this alright oops sorry
and how do you run it you ask okay so
for those folks who are not as familiar
with Jupiter notebooks you've got two
choices either you can click on the cell
and then you can click on this play
button on the right here oh sorry
on the right here okay the little play
button for both those of you who don't
want to hit such a small little play
button just shift enter so click on the
cell click shift enter and that will run
the cell for you okay alright so that's
what's going on here that's the first
step so what is this image okay like I
said we've got ourselves a 28 pixel by
28 pixel image with the size of 784 okay
that's what it looks like okay so for
example if I was to run this
specifically this M this train image I
want to get image two five one three
eight okay that specifically this image
alright
when I look at the label four to five
one three eight which is this one
basically it indicates to me for those
who are all fun on one hot encoding it's
the one is on the nine spot so it's for
the number nine okay so that's the label
that tells me what is the number for
this particular image okay the image
itself is actually here okay so now this
looks really weird right alright but
mainly because it's not a 28 by 28 so if
I actually scroll this image here's the
numbers so this is the digital
representation of the number of one of
the handwritten nines okay that's what
this is okay
in fact what I did is I actually
included oops sorry
this so I actually this is this it tells
you how anal I got basically you'll know
it's 28 pixels this way 28 pixels this
way this is Excel I took every single
number got in there if you zoom in on
the numbers you'll see the
1 9 whatever all this is there's actual
numbers ok so actually there's a hi-def
version of this image somewhere let me
see if I can find it oh here go all
right you guys want to know the
suffering I did for this one here we go
all right so here you go so you see
right here point one eight represents
the shading point six one represents
this shading 0.69 represents the shading
ok so that's how this handwritten digit
is represented okay so it's actually all
here again the notebook has it it links
to the image you can actually even look
at this image if you want to suffer for
some reason okay it is not a fun thing
to do because I had to export the data
out and then rewrite remap it and then
just you know it and I to use Excel
which is yeah God all right all right so
but that gives you an idea that's what
the digital representation of the number
looks like okay that's how it's stored
that's how you're looking at it okay so
now we're going to want to predict okay
so we're going to go ahead and talk
about okay this is actually the part
where Joy's going to talk about because
she's smart much smarter than I am but
the context basically is that we're
going to be using softmax regression to
actually figure this out go for all you
can leave us let you do you a [ __ ]
pointer if you want to the player yeah
oh the red light here for pointer so um
yeah - oh I think for most of the people
that are familiar with Disney or not
you're probably already know and
familiar with some softmax already which
is often applied at the last layer of a
deep neural net for for this a beginner
tutorial we are not using any deep
neural net yeah
ie we are not really using multiple
layers of convolutional layers yet we're
just using one single like classifier
for this beginner tutorial so so
basically all of the input that Danny
just showed that composed that number
we're just going to like sort of stretch
it into like
a single like I think three-dimensional
array which we call tensor here and then
we're just going to feed this whole big
number of arrays into a a classifier in
this case is the softmax classifier it
is a generalization of the logistic
regression so if you're familiar with a
logistic regression this is really sort
of just a multinomial a multi-class
logistic regression because we have
actually ten classes here right from 0
to 9 we have actually like instead of a
yes/no 1 0 also we are we have like 10
possible answers or categories that we
are trying to put the input number into
so to visualize to visualize how or to
get a better idea of how this works so
here's the an illustration of how do the
math work so basically you have a set of
inputs and for the sake of simple
illustration here we're just like
stretching for example if I see an image
of cat into the the array for X which is
the input we are getting here so we're
just stretching all the pixels into a
single column here and to train this
classifier we have actually a bunch of
ways here and then we have bias these
are all the parameters or like the
coefficients for our leader linear
classifier here so basically what we do
is we dot product W times X plus V that
is basically our function which is
basically what our model does and we
produce a score which is a sort of
classic or alsa like the probability
that our this function just gives to the
three potential categories I can't
dog and car and what softmax function
does is it basically exponentiate the
score and
normalize that to give you this better
if this probability with better
intuition so basically we take that roll
score out of the linear function that
we've just got a gut raw score and we
expose exponentiate the score into this
form so so we get B are pseudo sphere or
normal I uh normalized probabilities and
then we normalize them to get the other
probabilities and when you see here so
you see like the cat cat actually got a
really low probability of like only like
dog 0.01 sex which means this this model
basically the performance right now it's
really low it's giving cat with this
really low probability which means it
definitely needs more training where it
gives actually dark a much higher
probability means which means three
Alice's the output score the output is
actually wrong now and a lot of the last
function is the log of the probabilities
so you get the so the lower score you
get for the correct output the height
will higher the last s which means
you're losing a lot this is this model
is not working out for you and but when
you give like the correct output a
really hot like high probability then
you get nearly zero loss which means
your model is working right now so
that's how we do the whole like cost
optimization based on this last function
so that's how cool thanks to it and so
for more information we actually put
some links inside here and actually
inside the slides we actually have some
good links to other course material that
you want to dig into it just because we
didn't want to get too deep into the
math behind loss functions and weights
okay so this is a quick call out so the
implementation for this this is this
cell right here and actually you'll
notice it actually happens really
quickly here okay so basically you've
got a placeholder you put in the
variables for for the size of some one
hundred eighty four to ten
and basically you're just simply
implementing the softmax regression
which is literally just this line okay
so pretty sweet okay and from the
standpoint of tenza flow it's really
fast
you got softmax regression you can train
the model that's what this basically bit
of code base is most important aspect is
here basically you're basically batch
training the system okay and then once
you're good to go on that front we will
evaluate the model so basically all I
mean is value my logs more like we
already know what the actual value is
and we but we're going to see how well
this particular softmax regression
predicts the numbers in other words we
for the M this data we already know what
the labels are we already know for for
each image what the number is actually
supposed to be so now we're going to see
how well it can predict okay and in the
case of this hey it actually predicts
that 91% okay so it's not bad it's not
great but it's not that and it actually
also happened pretty fast point zero
four seconds on a six gigabyte point
eight core node okay so not in the CPU
not GPU actually not even point eight
more like point six seven or like that
okay so basically it's screaming through
that's pretty fast now again it's only M
this data so it's not a lot we for the
purpose of this tutorial that's actually
why we're doing investigate ways you
guys can run it and in the next section
we in fact actually had to reduce the
amount of training sorry test data we
had a run because we were obliterated
the size of the cluster okay because
it's only six gigabytes of memory and
0.67 core okay so you actually have a
lot larger data get yourself a real
cluster or real box or even one core and
then you can probably fix it so alright
cool did you want to do the cool all
right
go for
like no not as well sorry sorry I'll do
that one later
okay so Joe is going to jump into the
softmax direction from this standpoint
let me switch the softmax and start
repeated up to there go but the quick
call-out is basically this is from the
joy micelle actually all three of us
were pretty big fans of Andrew karthi's
course okay so that's CS 231 and if you
guys want to dig into the math behind
this stuff it's all available on YouTube
I've linked it we've liked it in the the
flight okay but if you want to dig into
it by all means go ahead and watch the
course it's on YouTube it's for free the
slides are available for free it digs
into the math behind all the stuff so
you can really understand not just the
intuition but also actually how it works
and here's the here's one of his many
JavaScript of us sorry like now we've
gone through the math a little bit and
this is really intended to give you more
intuition behind a mask
what is this softmax trying to do or
what is still like this linear
classifier trying to do from a intuitive
standpoint so what you see here this
this demo on the left so basically we
have some dots here grass green grass
blue dots each dot basically has two
it's a two-dimensional sort of data
point as you can see that's why like
it's in reality you can have a lot more
dimension like for your input for the
sake of simplicity of this demo we are
just like using a two-dimensional data
points here so we can more we can easily
visualize it on a flat flat flying like
this so each dot has obviously has a
value on the x-axis and y-axis that's
how we plot these stars on the plane
here and we have three different
classification categories
for these dolls basically that's the red
category the grain category and a Brule
category and that's what we're trying to
classify these stuff into we're trying
to classify them into three different
categories to read the okay the rash the
green and the blue so oh let me get some
so as you see if I try to change any of
the weight here so for example these
these weights points with these
coefficients actually are the classifier
for the blue Buddha so if I move this up
and down you can see actually is really
I can change the spatial boundary for
this root for this blue classifier for
where it should be really putting the
blue dot into the blue category here and
this this fires actually can affect my
position as well and now I'm manually
manually manipulating the position but
behind the scene if I'm trying to train
that that's what the algorithm is trying
to do is basically literally trying to
move all these classifier all these
straight line boundaries around to try
to find a boundary in a really a spatial
space that would put out that we
separate all these dots into the
category that they belong to that's what
intuitively is trying to do so if I run
on eyes so if I randomized the
parameters you can see now is it's not
really getting anywhere but then I try
to so every time I run on eyes as long
as the the the classifier is running it
will always try to go back and find the
proper boundary of separating all these
three categories of stuff in
to spatially into three different space
so that's why is trying to do it thanks
Joe and yeah for you guys who are
hopefully for you guys who are like that
that math look there go yes basically
what it comes down to this particular
JavaScript demo what you're trying to do
is basically you're trying to knock down
that loss function as low as you
possibly can because that means you're
actually going to go ahead and get it as
close to zero as you possibly can so
that means it's actually classifying the
data correctly that's what it boils down
to right so you know when we keep on
talking about things like weights and
hyper parameters basically this is you
well in a JavaScript console manually
manipulating the stuff that's actually
all that's going on here so it just
gives you some context than what how a
linear classifier how softmax regression
basically works in this context okay but
this is the starting point okay so now
that we've talked about soft mass
regression remember we said that the the
precision for the amnesty ADA was 91% we
know for a fact that that number could
go significantly higher than 91% 91% is
actually too low so that's where
convolutional neural networks comes in
okay so in other words let's get let's
do better than this because up to this
point it's basically been SVM's
maybe softmax regression but we actually
have not been able to get more precise
cnn's allow us to get more precise now
okay so slider oh look look yeah I think
we did notebook okay do I explain
section
and of course this is one yep let me run
it you cannot be this way now after
earlier
okay so right now we're going to be
showing you literally how we build a
convolutional neural network with tensor
flow this is still a single threaded
execution Danny will later walk you
through how you can do it in a tensor
frame setup but right now are we just
going to jump in and create an the
network that will help us to literally
recognize the the digits right so there
are two we've created two for our helper
functions right so the first one when
you see the conf 2d is actually creating
a 2d convolution so just to show off
hand guys how many of you are familiar
with how the convolution works okay all
right so just a quick our X our X over
this is our input data the W stands for
the size of the convolution right so
this is our filter this is the you know
how many pixels by pixel
you know while we look at the at the
same time and we apply a you know two to
our image in order to where you know
I'll calculate the the convolution from
that so that normally will be a some old
number so you will be added three by
three five by five this is our kernel
right we've wrapped this so this is
actual call to the trans of tensorflow
where we go spins of all neural network
inversion today it's just literally a
wrapper function around that so we don't
have to specify all the times the
strides strides here what it means it
actually how many pixels you offset when
you move loop for your whole image right
so we move one pixel at a time
in order to create our our you know
filtered image so in this case we will
move one left one
right so actually the middle ones they
specify one pixel at a time right and
one pixel a lot of the time low so go go
lower actually do you want me to show
that yes because you don't worry okay so
what what uh Tom's talking about here
basically is this so again we actually
incorporated this within the deck so you
guys can basically play with it for the
heck do I put it though not it oh there
you go
or it looks good oh cool yes yeah
alright so if I were wearing he's
talking with strides and strides and
basically a moon pixels so if this top
left okay or these represent the number
okay that you're trying to read okay and
this little squares you've got there are
pixels now again this is from and Raqqah
parthy we're not that smart
okay then basically this is the movement
of flow that's happening to read the
pixels okay inside your data so you're
not actually looking only one pixel of
time you're actually looking at a bunch
of pixels all at once okay three by
three five by five in that nature okay
and then it actually goes down and
drills valve in this case this is a
three by three the whole image is what
seven by seven if I read correctly yes
and it's destroyed is it moves two
pixels at a time right and two pixels at
a time low right so we start from the
top and then we move to the next one and
yet the next one right so we skip two
and then once we reach the end of the
image we skips another two two rows
that's how you can actually see over
here highlights when we move to the
middle one it actually highlights which
one we are are you know outputting from
this convulsion law convolution does
that make sense so far so good
all right so I think with this which I
have a notebook oh cool
so in this case we are actually not
skipping to we are moving one by one so
we read one column we will skip one
column at a time and one row at a time
the pairing the the final parameter that
the planning is actually when you think
about convolution and the way it was
shown actually on the on the on the
slide is that if you had a 28 by 28
pixel pixel image and you specified a 5
by 5 convolution kernel the resulting
image would be 24 by 24 and that's
simply the way the conversion works
because it will cut off to lows from the
top to loss from the bottom if you have
a 5 by 5 and then 2 rolls from the
through column from the left and the
crumbs from your life slowly from the
right exact resulting to in a 24 by 24
are you know resulting image resulting
features tensorflow is actually adding
some of those two you know two rows two
columns on each side so that's why
whatever comes out from the convolution
in terms of flow when you specify the
same time you also if we fit feed 24 8
by 28 image will get 28 by 8:28 feature
out the maps pool this is once again
this is our wrapper around the function
so this is our input and then we specify
the kernel size we specify the kernel
size two by two what the pulling layer
does is actually looking a 2 by 2
portion of the of the feature and in
averages the values that it sees in that
particular window so let's say we had 1
1 2 3 and 4 the resulting output from
that particular pulling would be my
memory what you say 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
Rises yeah yeah
and then we specify so in unlike with
the with the convolution here we skip 2
& 2 right so if we specify a kernel 2 by
2
then we don't look at these pixels
anymore we move to the next one two by
two
right and then next one two by two and
then same thing when we go lower
we don't read these pixels anymore we
move to the next three and four rows
three and four does that make sense
cool the weight variable this is
essentially the way we initialize the
weights so then the as we were talking
about the neural networks and how we
build them the way once the we decided
on the structure of the neural network
we need to actually specify some
starting parameters of the you know of
the of the ways that connect all of
these neurons just like with the you
know statistical statistical model if
you have some studying parameters when
you let's say estimate a multinomial
logistic regression right normally they
are hidden from you because they are
normally assumed zero and then the
algorithm takes us from that over here
we could have set up set it up to zero
but then we would get nothing at the
output so we initialize that to
something drawn from a normal truncated
truncated distribution so it's never
going to go below zero and with the
standard deviation of 0.1 so that we use
a variable because that's going to be
changing after we train our network it's
this is going to be a changing value
over that and then this is what the call
to this particular function returns and
then the bias variable is literally very
you know specifying a very similar
similar fashion fashion but instead of
drawing from a you know a distribution
we just specify that to the constant of
this case in this case this is zero
point one the shape if we say okay give
me you know 784 by one it will return
784 values single list if we specify
three by three will give us nine values
stuck into three by three the matrix and
then the final one we get the variable
there you go out cool okay all right so
yeah let's talk about the model then
we'll do is shift to the demo so okay
yeah so yeah
okay so in the input as I said we each
each image in the Minister said has been
transcoded to 28 by 28 I think
originally they were more than that
correct but for this purpose for the
purpose of this exercise and then in
tensorflow we working with the 28 by 28
representations of those handwritten
digits these get pulled through a first
convolutional layer so this conversional
layer has a kernel of 5 by 5 right so
we're looking at 25 pixels at a time and
then we literally skip one row one
column at a time so the resulting as I
told you like because we use the padding
equals same the resulting feature size
is also 28 by 28 right so that's the
first the first convulsion on layer
there's 32 features in this particular
one what do they do so the convulsion
essentially allows you to then he was
showing you that the Nano
when it was recognizing the are the
edges or was kind of you know starts to
recognize that which feature is the tie
to a face in this case what it actually
does is we're training the kernel so we
training the weights that are associated
with the kernel and that result in
either we invert the image or it
actually increases the contrast or it
actually inverts the image so that's how
the image representations in which
within those 32 features here this is
how it works so so just to add at some
point and when we're showing this now
this is intensive was actually using
Cafe Rococo correctly okay but the
call-out basically is that this should
give you some context that the first is
your input okay so forget about the the
sizes because what tensorflow does is
different the way this particular
implementation is but if you go ahead
and look this is the hand digit written
digit right here okay that's what it
goes when you run the first
convolutional network this is what the
numbers are going to look like now this
case is only well eight eight eight of
them okay in fact they're actually 32
features in the case of what we're doing
but the idea is that this is what's
going to start looking at so basically
it's building up
that's what the the layers are actually
doing so this is what the number more or
less looks like after the first
convolutional network okay
and they all will be different yes as I
was saying like it's some of them will
increase the contrast some of them will
help later on the later stage to detect
the edges and so on and so forth or
different distinct features of the digit
that you're actually trying to recognize
back in a book yep cool
so the pulling layer that as I was
explaining that it will actually go and
then shrink the image right so look at
two by two we're using two by two
kernels here it will actually shrink the
image to a 14 by 14 and this is because
we're using strides of two by two so we
never look at the same pixels over again
what it does is actually averages the
you know the number from four pixels it
will watch the shrink that two to one
yep so just just to add to that so
basically here's the pooling layer so it
is you're not seeing much of difference
between the two but basically if you go
ahead and look at this this is actually
after the first convolutional and the
activation function really of activation
function basically there's no difference
between this layer and this layer except
for the fact that instead in this case
is 24 24 to 12 12 okay so in other words
our numbers are different for tensorflow
but basically it's just basically half
the size that's what balls down to okay
so we've taken that image that we have
here and now we're shrinking it down
yeah that's that's what that's what the
pooling layer does okay great yeah
thanks
right so you can stop for for back to
the yep one I want to talk a little bit
about the real okay right did the
activation what you want to go here you
might have been okay so this is good for
it yeah so what you can see do you
remember the you know the slide with the
activation functions that you guys
showed you we had the real which is
outputting anything as you can see the
difference between this and this is
literally like we only output whatever
the input to the the neurons is up to
this layer is only if it's greater than
zero right so that's why you see lots of
sorry I'm a deposit so you can actually
see the difference
that's why you see lots of dark things
and only those highlighted pixels get
showed up right they only show up here
so there's a number of reasons why we
use this different implementations like
Danny and I would the the also
administer workshop a while back well we
use different framework we used a
hyperbaric tangent and it works fine the
problem is with the thumb hyperbolic
tangent when we trying to network and we
go beyond you know if the sum of all the
inputs gets getting into the neuron
exceeds around like I think to the
function because literally flat because
it peaks at one and then any subsequent
training to that neuron is literally out
of the question because the the
derivative in that point becomes zero
because it's laughing's
and then we cannot train that neuron a
neuron anymore so it essentially becomes
that from the purpose of using using
this Network real loose do not suffer
from that right so it is a simply a you
know are constantly rising or falling
function right depending on our you know
on the weight or how it's trained but
it's constantly you know there's no it
cannot ever reach a zero derivative so
it never becomes that that's why they
kind of like really state of the yard
right now and also very helpful are in
you know not making our making our
neural network dead okay cool thanks
that right enough up ok so right now we
are up the 14 by 14 right now what we do
is we create another convolutional
neural network or conversion your oh
sorry conversion layer right here so
right now we're going from 32 features
and we are actually expanding that 64
using exactly the same parameter so we
use five by five can also we loop again
for this 14 by 14 right now 14 by 14
image in order to create another 64
representations of the same image that
is already a little bit
shrunk down and with this we'll be
detecting a distinct distinct features
of the other hand with handwritten digit
the second pulling strings that shrinks
that image even further the 7x7
representation a call-out here is that
tensorflow
if you're at this point we would you
know we would end up with you know let's
say something like six and a half by six
and a half by the way the math works it
would actually plaid that to be seven by
seven so if there is an unequal or some
odd number coming necessary afloat
coming from the you know from the
pulling layer it will actually be padded
to something that is you know an integer
and then finally at the very end we
actually take all of these three
thousand closest you know thirty one
hundred a little bit over thirty one
hundred neurons from from this
particular layer and we squash them down
using a fully connected feed-forward
network what I mean by that is that if
you look at all of those 64 you know
seven by seven features all of those
seven by seven features would be
connecting to a 1,024 single a single
layer you know line of neurons right so
we we take 64 or 3030 100 and then we
actually literally connect them to a
layer of 1,024 1,024 neurons this
reduces our feature space and it is
further allows us to trained in the
network better and then in the final
stage just like Joey was explaining the
softmax we use the Arg max here to
actually you know squash it back to okay
we want to know what is 0 or 9 of 3 or
10 so we use our max so whatever we get
from squashing from ten thousand 24 to
10 we don't elect the winner or we can
call it winner takes all
kind of thing so whichever gets
activated with the highest value we say
okay this is the digit we want to assign
it to to our target so that's the that's
the output from
from away from our networks cool so just
to give you some additional context to
everything we just told you because
literally we just told you the code okay
on how this works okay
in fact the code is right here okay
that's it it's one sell everything we
justice plays one sell that's it okay so
to provide some quick context again
we've included this these links to these
demos already in here so like I said
before here's what the number looks like
input right and then even though the
numbers aren't the same it should give
you some context between what the input
was convolutional air activation pooling
convolution and remember in the end when
you're building these neural networks
that's all you're doing okay are you
doing is basically adding convolution
networks pooling maybe realization
convolutional network regularization and
then basically fully connected that's
really all that's happening just adding
tons of layers of this and so yeah if
your scroll down and so basically you
look at this right in this case it's
using softmax but basically it's
predicting it's zero right that's what
that's what it's doing right here and so
this is a example predictions for the
test set that it's been running on
JavaScript sorry so for example here all
the different numbers and it's all while
predicting so this they predict it's a
nine so vast majority of neurons are
indicating yeah this is a nine that's
what it's what it thinks these are there
so overall basically as time progresses
the network is actually doing a really
good job figure out what these numbers
really are okay in other words
minimizing the loss function that we've
specified in this case it's I think it's
awesome yeah exactly
so here's exactly that representation of
the loss function right here okay
initially as it starts off it's higher
for over time as it's learning more and
more information it's actually dropping
down dropping down dropping down okay so
that's the context of that the other way
of looking at this by the way if you
ever are able to go ahead and get the
the tool up and running and you're more
than welcome to go ahead and ping me if
you want if you have questions on how to
get this tool up running because like I
said I've got actually a pull request to
get it to fit to work the context is
that if you look at for example this
convolutional network layer you know
using the visualization tool right this
is what the pooling layer looks like
okay so each this is what the
normalization our regularization layer
looks like this is now another
convolutional air pooling layer so you
know say for example when I go from the
first layer right I have much larger
pixels when I get to the second layer
after I've pulled it I've got smaller
more pixels that's back to the same idea
of higher number basically I'm pulling
it down so in other words and I'm
doubling the size of the doubling the
number of features for me to work with
okay so this is basically that exact
same context all throughout and just
like we were demoing
our faces in terms of looking for the
edges basically this will sort of give
you the intuition of sort of
understanding how the network is working
throughout to sort of calculate or
understand how to identify those number
of the numbers or in this case and
pictures or images or us you know that
type of thing okay so it looks sorry
books books yes and one final note
before we actually just show you how it
happens well we didn't go through this
in the in the slides but they're
available here for you again to help
explain the concept we actually went
ahead and actually extracted like the
number nine and what it looked like and
so for each layer of the convolutional
network we actually sort of explained
well here's the code here's what happens
here's what the numbers look like so
that way you can take your time to
basically review all the stuff because
we knew we knew you just throw a lot of
stuff at us right now and so hopefully
the slides will help you sort of digest
what we just threw at you okay but
basically that one seller code is all of
this okay so again these slides are
available for you guys you can download
them and party-hardy that we're good to
on that one okay all right so you want
to run yeah okay cool
actually we already blew already run yes
so you guys can run this ugly is a quick
trick oh sorry yeah for when you for
this notebook just click on run all okay
you just run the entire thing okay it'll
take a little bit longer to run by the
way because it'll take a while for the
training to finish and then do me a
favor scroll one just what yeah keep
going
yeah okay yeah we um purposely oh no I
think it's actually no go down more
yeah there go yes we are purposefully
limited to 500 images okay as opposed to
all 10,000 test images not because we
don't want to do you to run it well
actually we don't want you to write a
bit mainly because because it's six
gigabytes point six of them course if
you go beyond 500 images for the test
it'll actually give you an interesting
nonsensical error but basically that
interesting nonsense of the layers
because it ran out of memory okay so but
basically if you scroll the way to the
bottom
still yep thank you basically if you run
this yourself on the full basically now
here you go here's the training at the
test accuracy ninety eight point nine
five percent okay so this is respectable
yeah pretty good at this one now now
we're we're feeling a lot more
comfortable so this is this is the heart
of why CN NS are super interesting for
us right okay yes question for the
testing or for the training yeah for
testing training for the training
500 should be enough to draw some you
know we can specify the standard error
on that look because don't forget even
if you're even like 500 is sounds about
right to me but the problem is that if
you have if the data has a lot of
variability then your host from that
standpoint right so if you've got a lot
of if you've got 500 like images that
are somewhat similar sure yeah
absolutely in fact the M this is a
perfect one in fact I think I only
trained on 1500 yet for the same reason
because I was running out of memory okay
so so the difference only how
representative your sample is right and
you can train statistical models with
the limited number of you know features
you use on probably I'm stretching is
probably 300 samples I wouldn't go that
far myself but you can do it but there's
always this you know how well this model
would generalize later on right so in
1500 we get to this right so the 90s is
7.5 you can probably go low and then
test it out we didn't do it for this
exercise you know how to do very that
but you can actually see oh we did that
for the 20,000 right yeah the 20,000
right here's a twenty thousand it goes
up so it depends how you know
later on how would that generalize and
you can definitely calculate the you
know an error around that it's just like
you know inference from you know when
you pull people and a new sample 1000
people you can always put a bound okay
it's plus minus 3 percent you can do the
same thing in this case okay cool
any other questions actually we're about
to switch gears to tensor frames so
that's more of the spark side will
actually probably finish it in about 10
minutes so this and so if you got
questions by all means ask now about
that way we can also get you guys out
early or if you guys want ask more
questions that's cool too so you'd
probably have to do it before you feed
into tensor flow so there are many tools
available to you in Python environments
right you could you could use Syfy
because you scikit-learn probably will
have also some statistical test to
determine whether your sample is
representative and has enough variance
to actually train on so you don't just
learn the features in your data set
that's why we always have this you know
you can see that that the training
accuracy is 1 so we learned that the
network learned perfectly what it was
you know trained with it learned
perfectly to recognize that but when you
actually fill it with a testing that I
said that it's never seen you can still
say it's generalizes very well all right
yeah I mean so just as a quick reminder
like when it comes to testing and versa
training remember the whole purpose when
you train in any ml model deep learning
model whatever it is the context without
a doubt is that you're going to have a
separate set of data for training and a
separate set of data for testing you
don't want to intermix those two so the
Emmis data is actually a perfect set
just because if you're starting off it
already has already it's a very split
here's your training data is your test
data and you're good to go
right but then there's various Python PI
spark whatever whatever tool you want
there's bear
is like you know tools you random array
or whatever else which basically will
take all the data split it for you so
that way you can say here's my training
data and here's my test data now the one
thing to remember so for folks who
actually have a lot less data this
actually it was common in healthcare
when you're doing machine learning
models for that you're going to actually
split from training data you're going to
have a cross validation set - actually
it was basically rehashing the training
data to validate the data looks right
before you apply to your test data just
because you don't actually have a lot of
data now that I'm going a little outside
the bounds but I was just a yes I just a
buzzer I can make double because well
you know so the context of just saying
is that you know in the case of a lot of
these samples that we have like for
example when it comes to M necessity
5000 training 10,000 testing in the case
to see C far there's enough images for
you to do it if you really want to play
with images go to image net okay the
image net has 15 million images so
you're good to go on that front but yeah
there will be some scenarios where you
ultimately won't have enough of the
training needed to work with and so then
that will be now you have to switch from
training to straight life yeah you have
to improvise and start doing cross
validation undo this another useful data
citizen IMS cocoa is actually from
Microsoft there's a bunch of images
would already have boundaries around
them so you can actually train to
recognize objects and there's also
captions written about that so you can
build a model that will do an auto
captioning yeah that's question that's
actually our job yeah it's a quite often
it's like a trial and error so the first
the first workshop that we run we only
use a six in six features in the first
gallery convolution and then 12 in the
second one and it would got to 97.5
correctly with 32 and 64 we got to 97.5
right so it's it's a try that we
probably will have to play in and then
try an error and another answer help not
if you have images then yes yes
yeah there's Noth nothing stopping you
as long as they purport to 28 by 28
right then if not they will have to
change the parameters of nerve yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah as the quick note is that
you can definitely upload your data into
there typically you won't upload it as
if you'll upload it basically as an
unzip a file but no you can still do it
I'm just omitting you just have to write
the extra line of code to unzip but when
you look at it that's all I mean by that
so basically you can certainly put the
images up there you can certainly run it
I do want to give you the heads up
because this thing barely ran because
again six gigabytes point six of course
you might want to go ahead and actually
run this on your own box or actually get
a larger set up okay when you're doing
it just as a quick call out again this
is the purposes of this is more like
just make it easy so I didn't actually
have to we all didn't have to go ahead
and stall various versions of Python and
anaconda or whatever else onto your box
and then we this actually would've been
a longer process for us oh sure
yes so the comment was that we should do
a rant we should have set the random fee
for reproducibility absolutely so the
part of the reason why I didn't do it at
the time was mainly because if I ran it
enough times that number actually would
have been higher and I did I forgot to
figure out what the seed was when I did
it so so in other words yes I was lazy
yes let's call a spade a spade so yeah
we're going to dust yeah yes yeah so
four times the frame are they useful
probably not for this one but if you
have a large data set right and also if
you want to like you do all your data
preparing preparation in you know in
spark environment then you don't have to
leave the whole environment you don't
have to save it to disk then we go
outside of spark and then read it again
and run it through tensorflow and then
save that another you know file read it
again in this park if you wanted to do
further work on spark so this is kind of
like keeping that within the same
environment so you don't have to switch
environments in middle so that make
sense wanna switch yeah old and clinical
any other questions then otherwise we'll
switch the sensor creams oh okay cool so
the here is the the final notebook that
we've got here and again with tensor
frames again I'm just going to run off
just to give you some context okay
basically we more or less in case you
when we originally designed this we were
originally wrote this note book with the
concepts that we're going to do a lot
less to flow more tensor frames and then
it became exceedingly apparent that was
very silly of us so we went ahead and
rewrote the course by the same token in
case you want to go to tensor friends
right away because you were already a
spark person we actually added some
additional info directly into the
notebook so you can understand the
concept of what tensor flow was okay so
we're going to skip all this okay but
basically it's just talking about the
mathematical operations and why using
placeholders okay that'sthat's all the
stuff is basically if you're already
using tensor flow the previous two
notebooks you're already
doing what I what were just showed you
here okay is that we're making explicit
for those who are basically coming from
more of a spark background and you're
jumping into attention frames tensorflow
from there okay
so then like we had noted under the
tense of flow spark that the frames on
my section basically here's what tensor
frames does it is a wrapper around
tensor flow for the purposes of if you
are trying to work with the data that
already exists in spark number one or
number two you are trying to determine
the hyper parameters okay so in other
words just like what Tom and I were
talking about before and what joe is
talking about before two is that you
don't know what values you're going to
use for those hyper parameters since you
don't know what they are you're going to
try a lots of different things well you
can either like do you I manually change
the bias right and apply that to a
million things or you can automate that
process so the context is that you can
automate that process by using tens of
frames to basically help you calculate
what a lower loss function is going to
look like and calculate what's the
optimal set of hyper parameters for you
to work with okay so that's that context
and let's see so then when you look at
tensor frames itself basically it's just
this code here okay so basically I'm
first for those again who are more spark
related this is the cell all I'm doing
here saying okay I'm going to import
tensor frames and I'm going to create a
data frame a data frame is I'll now list
to a table so how many of you guys know
pandas by chance okay excellent thank
God okay all right so basically it's
analogous to a panda's data frame okay
it's not pandas dataframes actually
really freaking cool so I'm not going to
say it's the same thing
what the data frame with inspark is is
analogous to it but it allows it it's
very well designed from a distribution
perspective okay so again when you're
talking about sparks sparks coup de gras
its main focus is about distribution
okay
so I know plenty of people who will then
do all their data all their processing
with their data and once they're done
they're actually go back and put the
state and put the spark data frame into
a pandas data
so they can run run their queries again
using pandas that's completely cool and
provided that you're not dealing with a
massive large amount of data okay I'm
talking like the kinds of millions
hundreds of millions it providing you're
not doing that we go for yeah run pandas
run so I could learn I think that's an
awesome thing to do
so no debate on that one okay but
basically I've just created data frame a
spark data frame not pandas spark
dataframe here and this is just what it
looks like okay it's really boring okay
X here's the numbers zero tonight okay
yay okay all right so that if I want to
do an addition okay basically a tensor
graph okay basically I'm going to do a
block by block addition so the context
that we're coming from so even though
it's not obvious when you're looking at
this because it's really simple code all
I'm doing is this like I'm doing P of s
block and I'm doing an ad and I'm doing
a map blocks okay for something this
small this should have just been done in
Python okay you should you should never
bother doing this will spark okay but
the context and the reason why we're
doing this is because in this case block
is referencing spark block management
okay so when you're working with spark
you're dealing with lots of data that's
distributed across multiple nodes okay
when your each piece of data that you're
dealing with each each chunk of data
basically is a block of data so what
we're doing is when we're doing the
additions or multiplications or whatever
it is you're doing within the context of
spark you're doing a block by block
calculation that's where this map blocks
comes in here okay so it'll be
fundamentally more efficient when you're
dealing with that large amount of data
to the to perform the calculation block
by block as opposed to performing it one
cell by one cell okay especially because
this data is distributed across multiple
nodes okay so that's the key facet here
or tensor frames the thinking is a
little weird if you are not coming from
a spark perspective you're not coming
from a district computing perspective
this seems like an inefficient way of
doing things and you are correct okay
all right but for those who are actually
used to working within the context of
distributed computing this is the most
efficient way of doing things that's the
context here okay and then now that
we've done it I can basically just
output the data frame and then
yay not terribly complicated again for
the small amount of data I just added
three but again this is now done block
by block so that's what this particular
output is showing right now okay
and the key aspect now so we did not
show an EM missed example for this one
just because we ran out of time to write
it but basically the context is a lot of
the functions that you're going to do
when it comes to interacting between
tensorflow
and spark are really element wise
calculations element wise some element
wise multiplication things of that
nature
okay and so basically the context of
this particular code is that okay number
one I built the data frame number two I
actually now because I'm going to be
dealing with a massive amount of data
potentially okay I need to actually
build a schema I need to tell it what
the size of this data is so I can
efficiently tell spark how to distribute
the data across the wire and have
tensorflow
actually there's one question who's
saying can I make sure that when I'm
running a tensor operation I don't cut
it at the wrong edge basically that's
the whole point of this these set of
tasks that I actually will only work
with in the context of that particular
piece of data okay so in this case if I
look at the print schema of the data
frame you notice that actually I have no
idea what is it's double but I have no
idea what the sizes so again common
within the context of spark you're going
to run the TFS analyzed now again it's a
small amount of data for here but when
you're dealing with a lots of large data
you want to be able to know what the
array size is and so that's why running
TFS analyze is important so before spark
tries to make sense of this before it
tries to distribute it it actually knows
the size of the data you're dealing with
okay and then that's basically this
analyze this portion of it and then
finally I can do the L amount and why
some and then some min min excuse me and
so basically this code base right here
basically that's it
okay execute the tensor graph basically
now I'm doing this block by block that's
it
okay and so a lot of the the api's are
completely available at 10 2 frames 10
frames like github io so basically you
can look at all that's available
here but we've actually put a lot of the
the key examples right here for you to
work with but basically once you've done
that then you actually can return the
element wife some and then from your
spark data frame pushed into tensorflow
extract it out back into a data frame
for you to play with again okay and so
again it's a very elementary example but
the context is that most of the time
when you're dealing with any data if
it's a large amount of data you're going
to have to start playing on the
distribution side of things so tensor
frames basically helps that within the
context of spark you can throw the data
into tensorflow
do its magic once you get the output a
tensor flow you want to do something
with that your action is okay I see the
number nine correctly okay that means
I'm going to go do that'll trigger
something else because I'm running for
sake argument a machine learning
algorithm downstream or I'm running
spark streaming downstream so now I'm
actually able to do that okay so I think
that yeah that's it for this section
yes questions
correct so learning to repeat what you
said first so in the background what he
said is in the background I'm doing the
calculations in a distributive fresh
distributed fashion via tens of frames
but it is interacting with tensor flow
that is correct yes The Times okay so
essentially the agent that is doing the
holder computation yes yeah cool yes
you'll if you want to know the block
size you will have to determine that
yourself but most the time you actually
don't the the basically the the Y size
of the of the of the matrix is all you
actually need to know because it's
purely there so that way spark itself
knows how to distribute it so yourself
actually don't need to know this
information is just more matter you've
got to run it so spark is now aware of
this that's the key aspect here okay yes
question there so the question is are we
talking about an automated fashion or we
talked about actually manually changing
it and in fact actually I would say it's
more of the latter which is manually
changing it but it actually allows you
to get to the automated because in the
end the output of those various high Pro
primers is the loss function ultimately
right which is basically you're just
trying to hit the lowest number
there's an interesting supposition by
Andrew Parthi about the fact that in
most machine learning and deep learning
cases the local minima the one that we
thought that was going to screw us over
basically in fact actually nearly isn't
nearly as bad as we think it is and so
just long you're throwing enough hyper
parameters at it and you're running it
long enough you'll actually get past the
local minima and it'll actually hit the
global minima okay so I even I had to
felt uncomfortable things like it was I
was not used to that idea but from from
a lot of the parties and a lot of other
of these you know deep learning like the
ions these awesome guys and gals who
understand the stuff basically they've
come to the conclusion at least from
neural networks reflexive the local
minima wasn't actually nearly as a big
of a problems I thought it would be yeah
so you said you are right it will get
too automated but you you still have to
sort of do a little bit of it yourself
to get there yeah okay cool cool
question there okay okay I'm going to
repeat your question so everybody can
hear it and make sure and I make sure I
get it right okay so in the context of
GPS where is the data line is that
correct
perfect okay within the context of GPUs
the whole reason why GPUs was
problematic in the past is that number
one they were relatively small so they
can only hold so much memory number two
when you were doing a mem copy from the
CPU to the GPU that took up so much time
that basically you were host:okay a lot
of the work that was done in the last
six or seven years basically allows us
to do the string copy mem copy from the
CPU directly the GPU is extremely
quickly so long story short the answer
is it's on the data is now residing on
all the nodes or I shouldn't say all the
node whatever stock decided whatever
notes Marc thought it needed it will
then be the data reside in memory there
and it'll be access if you enabled GPU
support it will then put the data into
GPUs so the GPU will do the calculation
for you as opposed to CPU every demo
that we've done today is immediately
enough doing CPU mainly because I want
this to be free for everybody but by the
same token if you were to enable GPU
support or you ran this on your own
cluster with GPU support then that's
exactly what would happen yeah so
basically from a spark perspective last
year we had basically put in all the
extra code to ensure that we could
number one recognize GPUs the number two
basically put it there not just in a
single fashion that was what we did late
last year but early early this year also
to put it in a distributed fashion so if
you had multiple GPUs on a single box
we'd actually be able to go ahead and
use multiple GPUs for the calculation as
well okay cool yes
sure so the question was roadmap on
Keros I can honestly not tell you what
the roadmap of Harris is right now it's
definitely a very very very popular deep
learning tool so yes I think you guys
definitely if you're interested the
Charis is something you definitely
should keep up on from a tensor frames
perspective actually come join us we are
actually actively writing the code to
basically take on more of the sense of
flow API to make it easier to for the
two to work together sense of flow yeah
that's easy just go to Google site and
you'll see the tense of flow roadmap
yeah yes that's right on it Samet so
there you go
I'm sorry oh it's out of eat one it's on
a Google and be mine and not yeah I
haven't seen another one yeah sorry now
right now sorry
yes well actually yes I forgot let me
good point and he reminded me and I
completely still spaced out on this okay
so in the slide deck here when you get
past all this other stuff you go to the
finale part we have a whole bunch of
really good inferences in step we've
actually
inter laid in here because these people
are fundamentally smarter than we are
okay so definitely read up on some of
the stuff one of them actually is
exactly this integrating deep learning
libraries within the Apache spark and
that actually so basically the database
open sourced as part of Sparks on that
this year the deep learning pipelines
and the first two the most important two
were tensorflow and caris so yes so
basically they're already integrated
you're more than welcome to go use it
there's actually some pretty decent
documentation already written up on how
to use both but conceptually it's very
similar in terms of how to interact with
sparkle cares it's very conceptually
similar to how attentive frames already
tend to flow yeah okay
yes the the supposition is that this
tends to frame blunt me go more into the
weeds absolutely because from a
distributed engineering perspective it's
awesome when I can go ahead and do the
data science I can run the deep learning
malls but at some point this becomes too
large and I got to understand how the
data is distributed because the single
node itself will break it simple so
understanding that both the concept of
deep learning pipelines intensive frames
allows us to go ahead and actually start
manipulating something back yeah cool
cool yes manually we start which
features more equality absolutely so in
machine learning Laura that's basic like
you're running PCA for sake argument
right but basically you have now more
than enough data in your network to
basically go back identify which set of
features is that actually or coming into
play and this is actually when we start
going to do yeah when we show the demo
when we were saying okay this particular
feature is recognizing faces the other
one is actually learned to recognize the
text yeah right right that's pretty much
you would have to dig deeper and that's
why I was referring to you know neural
networks being more of a black box a
little bit in that first because you
have to actually write stuff on top of
that in order to extract that
information that is normally given to
you by running a statistical model but
wouldn't you unless it's doable but it
requires a little bit more work exactly
yeah and sorry question the back sorry
yes so in other words for all you guys
who are using the database cluster the
clusters will shut off automatically but
because you have an account all the data
is saved so you actually have nothing to
worry about you you it's in fact
actually one cool feature that I
completely forgot to show you guys is
that if you decide to go ahead and
change it click on revision history and
actually the real whole revision history
of your notebook is actually kept here
so you can go back to the one that
actually you didn't screw up on because
I am absolutely guilty of doing that
regularly so oh well yes
okay cool cool all right well then hey
thanks much